celebrating its 40th anniversary in
style the European Union visitors
program the Tyker EU visitors program
sounds like it's a holiday but in fact
this is a very high level induction
awareness training and networking for
people outside of the European Union to
try and tell them about the European
Union established in 1974 alumni include
former heavyweight of us diplomacy
Richard Holbrooke also here to collect
an award the EU commission of a regional
policy who said her career started with
a visitor's program it was in 97 and
nobody would have believed that 18 years
after that I would be here for a week
invitees meet em eps and representatives
from the Commission's I think I'm a
little bit clearer on the
differentiation between the Commission
the Parliament the council but maybe a
name change between Council of the
European Union and European Council you
might want to think about that but could
a program like this also affect change
in third countries well for one
participant Europe's discussion on
lengthening maternity leave sparked
interest that inspired me to amend our
maternity leave la in Jamaica so
definitely something worthy of some cake